Before we say goodbye,
let's play a quick round of Drewth or Dare.
(audience clapping)
And, today, we have Beth.
Hi, Beth.
Hi, Drew.
I'm so excited to do this with you.
Oh, this is so exciting.
Thank you for having me.
Well, what's it gonna be, Drewth or Dare?
It is a dare.
Okay.
You know I'm willing to do anything.
Anything at all?
Yes.
All right, so I do a little bit of working out.
I don't do a lot.
Okay.
Don't have the best upper body strength,
so I thought maybe we can share this experience together.
I love it.
Let's do push-ups.
Okay.
What do you think?
Let's try it.
Now do you wanna do lady push-ups
or do you wanna do the actual push-ups?
I'll probably go for lady push-ups.
All right, do you wanna do do it together?
Yeah, let's do it together.
Cool.
Okay.
Okay, you ready?
Just keep going?
Ready?
(audience clapping)
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
You feeling it?
Yes.
(Beth laughs)
Eight.
Nine.
10.
Do you wanna keep going or you had enough?
(Beth laughs)
(audience clapping)
Ah.
Is that enough?
(audience cheering)
Made it.
Thank you.
Thank you, Beth.
(upbeat music)